[Music]
all right how's it going bros my name is
Pippa I'm here with my team micro hey
not friends we're gonna play Star Trek
what's the game Nicole ha ha ha ha and
Star Trek bridge crew so I guess we
that's what you are you're my bridge
crew there you go
we're gonna be randomized who we are in
the game we could be a man
give me a female but we're gonna get
into it are you guys ready
how so ready oh yeah let's go in gosh
captain Harris ha yeah yeah shut up
Gaia this is so [ __ ] weird ok are you
ready yeah captain nice guy I want to
have some [ __ ] Roger Roger ok sure oh
jeez
what's happening should I do the bashing
ramp run
okay kid oh my go to complicate [ __ ]
okay father
Oh Oh - hey
[Music]
we are the hottest crew in this galaxy
yeah
am i we're all black guys you can see
yourself if you press like B you can see
what you look like I'm pretty just
punching the screen whoa because hahaha
this is so cool hey PJ how you doing
over there hey what's up hey hey hey
Randy reduction my armies oh I can see
myself what are you doing help oh okay
mm-hmm thank you I'm rubbing my nipples
in the air oh sorry all right
our mission is to render aid to research
station assess the status of research
station a low for all right let's do
that [ __ ] oh I'm telling the [ __ ] oh oh
hang on all right over there I'm
freaking out all right higher by
preparing to warp guys I'm preparing us
to walk oh no no no no I don't know
rather walk okay
hello--hi so much I love you so much
sixty Seconds to warp time wait no we're
not ready to walk should we just turn
the wall for like what No
oh good jump engine good job good well
Kitty Jay pitcher Joe Joe Joe John don't
shoot the survivors brain I'm scanning
for life signs
survivors are like oh they're survivors
my friend
I'm reversing Killa over there so do I
need to walk over there wait who's
warping over what me a huge traffic you
should go
hey Jay what's over there you got it
yeah you need to work on a good editor
we're walking right yeah man you all
right
Brad definitely one more all 10
kilometers cargo transporters I
transported some cargo black people for
us six are you safe sick people there's
two more pods you go do that job well
done Jay Wow
nice guys appreciate it appreciate you
whoa Sean oh this is a bad night
I put up [ __ ] show up everyone calm down
I'm gonna chase this big our shields are
26% environmental health he's left all
right let's go into the Sun okay what
fat I trust you brought let's go through
the Sun that seems like a great idea
no I'm saying war feeding I wanna listen
to Miami captain I listen to all listen
to him peril I trust I wish [ __ ] and
[ __ ] you
I know everybody Shawn you have all the
calling with off those legs like no
juice your hands and your attacks go
James o'clock again
great job everybody that was okay I
think we may have left some people
behind but Paco all right guys this time
trying to be less [ __ ] now this time I
will bread and the engineer oh no no no
no we need to do the same thing this
time I want bread whatever the [ __ ] we
need there we go welcome officer a table
number two no this time we gotta do it
right
that's a nice vessel you've got a lovely
vessel oh so I'm a vegan but you're
flying blind hey how's it comin practice
whoa having space with my beautiful
space crate hey guys check out I'm gonna
use the yang names down dad Brian our PJ
now watch me with oh yeah the station
was studying a dwarf star the persistent
you're the closest to me what are you
doing Piggy's talking he's playing a
synthesizer
I need to come on oh damn oh hello oh my
god oh yeah
we have to save all the survivors 10 no
pulling out I think that maximize
sangeun power ok I'll put it back to max
there are survivors over there save the
survivors over there please hmm no life
signs I just said survivor sound so
frozen shut shut up jack like [ __ ] up I
cannot get used to these boobs every
time I look down this ok stop fondling
your tits sorry I apologize no guys I'm
looking people I can see people hold on
assigning whatever so wha no survivors
I'm beaming it up beam them up Mon very
good
yeah six out of six okay Brad we need to
go right transfer going right wait wait
wait wait wait wait
transporting cut trailer montage
slumming hey guys we're gonna nail it
this time degree I'm dead calling me the
wrong name
what I'll wait to clean up those sons of
[ __ ] scanty hair no one period Oh God
very Eric kill him
I'm trying but I'm sitting up my
torpedoes Jack for once
shoot your damn torpedoes their charges
your Brian taking that back now we're
going in shields going up
go ahead come on kill him
are we gonna hit this thing swap swap go
torpedoes no going Brad sign in a bag no
stupid Klingons thought they could [ __ ]
with us
Mario I was playing on Felix I think we
got em so [ __ ] they're behind us
actually no no only afford a torpedo is
that captain okay they're at 46% pull up
we're looking on the people beginning to
survive this hold on where are the
survivors I'm getting them home Adam
payback we're beaming in the survivors
Riordan nice target respond it dies you
guys Brenda who died this little out
here oh Lisa no no it's okay she's
replaceable all right dr. Brad we're
ready to walk everyone
yeah 18 out of 18 come on come on grab
ah come come come on come on show me
that yeah yay that was really good
that is great I'm so glad that we
stopped teasing everybody
we saved everybody our team could be a
great starship team experience you're
right torpedo with the [ __ ] out of those
guys time to ship around sometime I'm
terrible
all right breast I hope you enjoyed this
video I just want to give a quick thanks
to Ben and Sam from the UK team and
Ubisoft for setting this up this was a
little bigger project and that thanks to
Michael as well Michael yes
thanks to Michael as well from putting
this all together thanks to Brad PJ I
guess Jack as well for being part of
this video I hope you bros enjoy it if
you did leave a like and I appreciate it
and though it brofist
you
[Music]